[Music]
don't be a fake
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe hey babe hey babe hey
[Music]
what's up buddy how you doing babe good
man what's uh what's going on with your
eyes
yeah i i i got cream in them
uh dad no i put like uh i got this i had
this burt's bees
okay uh little little like you know just
moisturizer
sometimes i get dry you know i like to
tend to it i like to ignore it
yeah i got i got the solution for you
are you ready for this i
because because from looking at my phone
so much and a lot of people i'm sure
suffer from this
looking at a computer looking at a cell
phone your eyes get so dried out
i got these drops they're fake tears
they're actual fake tears because your
tear ducts dry out
and then you put that in and i can't do
that what do you mean
i can't put i've never been able my
entire life to put it not one drop
has ever hit my eyeballs do you mean
i have a terrible ocd um do you see my
see my right eye right there has a big
red mark yes yes
i this is a i sustained an injury at the
hands of my sister
what happened she hit me in the face
with a malibu ken doll as in
ken and barbie mattel right yeah it was
like when we were younger
shout out to tell doug and melissa
though we like doug melissa puts puts a
little bit of a better product
doug and melissa is really doing things
now with children's toys that i haven't
seen anyone in the market do for quite
some time
shout out doug and melissa douglas sal
and i will be opening up
uh different boxes of children's toys on
the patreon
yeah we might do unboxings that's it
yeah we just you know there's a lot of
plastic
going out right but doug and melissa
really work in
just upgraded materials a lot of woods
and and textiles
right much like the creator of bitcoin
nobody knows who doug and melissa
actually are and they don't know if they
exist or if they're a clandestine
conglomerate that's right that made the
toys
a lot of people think it is doug stanton
melissa mccarthy right that they
they came together and did a toy store
but it's not it's just not true yeah
yeah it could be the cia even we don't
even know yeah you don't know who the
hell it is
i um i i did this thing where i put a
little cream here and
uh it i think it got into my eyeballs
and now they're just
tearing my body's working the way it's
supposed to be but let me ask you a
question though what do you mean you
can't you mean your eye like you have an
anomaly in your eye like your eye
physically will
bounce the drop back i can't ever wear
uh contact lenses
i can't no my eye won't my eye will not
stay open to accommodate the drop
so genuinely if you had us government
secrets let's say you're the guy that
has the government secrets
and you get kidnapped by isis isis
doesn't have to put you in a cage and
threaten to burn you alive they don't
have to say we're going to behead you
all they have to do is say tell me what
your government's hiding you say no and
then they come out
this big huge terrorist comes out with
an eye drop thing like this and he says
now do it
you spill the secrets everything
everything
everything for everything literally if
he's like that you're going to start
spilling you don't understand
i can't even look at like a cartoon or a
movie or an action movie where someone
gets hit in the eye or stabbed in the
eye
or do you want it like that you ever
seen ray allen ray allen
uh ray i'm sorry alan ray from the
university of connecticut basketball
game get his eye poked out in the game
no pull it up no no no pull it up come
on i don't know if i'll be able to allen
ray
what do you mean he gets his eye he gets
does i get poked or do you see his
eyeballs attached or something like that
let's take a look if his eyeball's gonna
detach i won't be able to view that
yeah here we go um no it doesn't detach
wait where is the this is this is just
clips of allen ray
this is just allan ray's highlight reel
he was a
fantastic player not from university he
played for villanova i apologize
who wants to know who wants to know
remember that song yeah
and here it is yeah so he gets poked in
the eye and then if you see in slow
motion
his eyeball you see how that white dot
pops out his eyeball gets popped out of
its socket but it doesn't detach
but you see quickly if you look quickly
you'll see a white mark
boom right there hits him right on the
noggin oh my god
so that would not be good for you oh my
god
now he's then did he have to retire they
fixed him i think they might have fixed
i mean i think they fixed them i don't
think that i think no he didn't retire i
don't know that he didn't make the nba
but he or he maybe he didn't make the
nba but he didn't retie he didn't retire
after no he
he continued to play that was that was
uh
yeah where's he playing now villanova
we've played for villanova and mighty
made he's from brooklyn new york shout
out brooklyn
uh but that was the worst eye injury
i've ever seen shout out iron juice i
i uh i i uh i yeah i have a
i don't we never spoke about this i
can't even have things pointing my way
well no i knew that because i never i
never talked to you about it but you
know quite often through the times we've
been doing this podcast you will
you'll push in the corner of the pillow
oh yeah over more on the road
i'll turn turn anything pointing at me
so yeah nothing could go anywhere near
my eye and when i'm over
stimulated because i think it has to do
with adhd and ocd and all that stuff
besides the ptsd a lot of acronyms
right but um i i can't even like uh
i can't even bring myself when i'm over
stimulating my eyes
are hypersensitive right you're going to
laugh at me sometimes when i
am flustered and i feel like
i have uh you know sensory overload
right
um i can't even look out of my eyes like
i if
no joke if i want to watch television
like a couple of weeks ago i i was so
over stimulated my eyes were bothering
me so bad
way to live i uh i had to put on
sunglasses in the house to watch
television
wow because the actual tv screen was too
bright for me and i was sitting
downstairs in my own home with
sunglasses on at 10 p.m
watching like bob's burgers that's why i
have mine on right now i have the same
thing
are you serious really are you serious i
just thought you were a slave to fashion
i am but no i get bad uh migraines where
i lose vision for an hour
there you go so that's why you've always
had those you've never told me but
i've been working with you for two years
you've never told me about that i just
know you're like willy wonka's cousin
you've been working with joe derosa for
two years you didn't even know how old
he was
no he's like yeah i think he's somewhere
between 40 and 90. do you even know how
old i am do you even care about me i'll
cut you open and look at your rings
right now
right now i got three minutes 36. i'm 36
years old
august 26 1984. yeah
is a wild year because i mean they wrote
the book about 1984 84 is a
banger of a year i'm also 76 i'm a
bicentennial baby
i got a great year 84 is is a great year
dude yeah
you got mad that's madeline's rookie
year and it's don maddling's rookie here
that is mattingly's rookie year and
maybe even jordan no 85
i think jordan was a 1984 draft a lot of
things happened in 84.
big news in 84 what happened gandhi was
assassinating 84. there you go
gandhi was by his two sikh bodyguards
what yep gandhi was assassinated in 84.
you know at the end of gandhi's life he
was hated by
most of india should i reveal that i
didn't realize that gandhi was
assassinated now or later
would say do it now yeah i didn't
necessarily recall
that he was a sad you knew he was dead
though i knew he was dead i didn't
recall
it was by by via assassination right you
know but there's a lot of things i know
that
probably other people like how do you
think sam cook died i don't even know
who sam cook is
well that's not true sam cook he's one
of the greatest voices
of the history of every generation
what's it once
a million hits he died at the age of 33
he was involved in a very mysterious
death where he was murdered i believe
what's one song he did i i
i mean i mean one song is even like
where do i even begin
do you know sam cook is pimp have you
heard of sam cook i probably only know
him from sampled rap music
but you've never heard of sam keller's
he's never heard of
old sam cook is sam cook is a
timeless sam cook is like saying ray
charles sam cook is like saying otis
redding
you know what it's writing i know ray
charles i don't know what it's reading
you know otis i know oh the spunk to
meyer no the cookie i mean god bless
good great cookies
yeah you don't know who otis elevators
you otis elevators
i've heard i've heard of what's the same
otis redding yes
if you i i'm being honest if you asked
me to guess i threw my balls back you're
about to blow
up again i swear to god if you ask me
right now who was otis redding i would
think he
i my first guess would be he used to
play for the knicks
holy [ __ ] dude i mean i'll give you the
layup otis redding
okay sitting on the dock of the bay
can you sing it a little bit no are you
kidding me sitting on the dock
do you know sitting on the dock of the
baby son
oh yeah i'll be sitting when the evening
comes
watching the ships rolling hey babe
then i'll watch them roll away again
oh i'm just sitting on the docker hey
babe
watching the tide roll away
it's one of the most famous songs in the
history of music
i don't cook had 30. that's not even
otis writing is
that's bush league of threading
okay no judgment zone because i love
this is my music no soul and funky and
like early
is my music so that's what i i i
this is my essence in music is soul
music you remember wait do you remember
do you remember i won't say its name but
do you remember
when we were at that pool in nashville
you were at the pool in asheville and we
saw a singer who you are a huge fan of
who you are like a humongous fan of this
guy yeah and we saw him and like you
have been getting recognized people
you know knew who you were he saw it and
then you walked up to him and said what
a big fan you were and he treated you
like you couldn't like he was about to
call security security
that was i really we were in nashville
we were on the road there was this hip
new place right it was like cold like
the like there's just to be a motel
yeah it was awesome now what they did
was they took the concept of a roadside
dive motel
right but they made it new and vibrant
and trendy it was awesome and hip and
they had this old-school
bar area that looks like a basically a
vw post
right is that they say that right vfw
posts but your eyes are drive so yeah my
eyes
uh and and and it's one and then they
did the pool side and it's people with
motel rooms but they have this great
menu and they have a dj
and they they it was great whoever did
that as a visionary right
and so we went and we hung out at this
daytime pool party
great food drink vibe atmosphere right
and you and i
were in the pool together we had a great
time and then a
famous singer let's decide
as we go if we want to reveal who it is
only because
i forgot i don't know if it pays off
yeah but there's a person now that's
like
grammy nominated yeah and great musician
i'm it's my current favorite musician
right
still oh so still he's your favorite
musician even after that amazing great
uh one of my favorites without a doubt
top five ten people that i think are
doing the most exciting things in music
right now right
okay leon bridges leon bridges okay
that's who it is yeah
and i i've seen this guy in concert
i know every single syllable it was just
both on studio albums
and all of his all of his peripheral
signals
with krung bin and all this other stuff
and i'm not
i i love this man yeah i love this
person i think he's one of the most
talented people i've seen in decades he
is
and he caught he ended up attending this
pool party yes
and i'm not sure if people just
respected his space or didn't
necessarily know who he was
right or say i don't know if he's like
an everyday
name in every household but anyone who's
hip to anything about music
or friends or fashion or they know him i
didn't know
anything i didn't know anything about
his music at all but he stuck out to me
he stood out because the guy is a star
because how cool he dresses he had
a cool hat and it was in these i think
he might have been in like polyester
bell bottoms but like seriously with a
tight tank
but he's got the chains and he has a
beautiful big rimmed hat yeah
he's cool as [ __ ] he's wearing platform
shoes and he was getting down
he was he was dancing to the band next
down baby when we're grinding
i get so excited
[Music]
and leon bridges was dancer to that yes
and he was like really he had like
back up he was doing like slides he was
he was
unbelievable he was great and everybody
like you could tell that he was somebody
because he just
radiated he just he just looked cool
he's
cool yeah he just looked awesome and he
was in his zone
and i and i caught it and i said i think
that is leon bridges who i think
is the preeminent musician right now but
why it was so insane that that was leon
bridges is because
an hour before that when we're on our
way to that hotel you were playing that
music and you were talking to your
friends and everyone else who was there
with us
saying how much you guys love leon
bridges i was like who is that
and you played them for us in the car i
was like you have no idea what this
guy's doing
with every record and he still gives you
the
best of that sound it's unbelievable
right
and this is a guy i admire that i've
seen in concert and
i didn't want to bother him i'm i i'm in
the public eye
i get it i get when people sometimes see
me and when
i i've i've been in this camp i've seen
people that i admire and i'm like
well i may never see this person again
this is my chance to at least tell them
what they mean to me possibly um from
being in that position sometimes
i've learned that there's a right place
in time and
i want to be able to receive everybody's
uh
affection the same way but i'm a human
being and sometimes it's bad like one
time
people were i was with my dad in the
emergency room
right my dad was having heart
palpitations people were like yo bro you
need to take a photo with us
my dad's having palpitations yeah and
they were like why are you being like
that bro
right i was like you're wrong you're
wrong yeah so there's a time in a place
you know whatever yeah
i know you're you're out of all the
people i know in the public eye
you i think do it the best because you
get mobbed the most and you just
are the kindest of people the one time i
saw not that i ever saw you get mad the
one time that i got mad for you but i
didn't say anything was we were in an
airport i forgot what city well i know
the city but i want to out it
but we're in this city in the airport
and we're about to go we're going
through tsa and the tsa
lady who's out who was at the who was at
the you know bag
place like putting the bags through the
x-ray machine she's like yo you know
you have fun practicing jokers and i was
like and i was like okay whatever and
she goes and you were like yes you were
so kind you're like yeah hi how are you
know thanks for the support oh we walk
yes we start walking a bait she leaves
her post
starts to call her girlfriend i believe
on facetime or snapchat video or
something like that
she's like yo this this is my man from
the impractical jokers put me live on
live feed yeah three people walk through
tsa not checked
so i swear to that's why i'm bringing up
i was i witnessed i walked through tsa
with wicks coming out of his shoes yeah
and you know what day this was september
11th
december 7th yeah i don't even know what
that means anyway
pearl harbor yeah yeah but i was just
trying to pick another day and then for
me uh
could you imagine you caused sal calls
pearl harbor
and i said uh so he was dancing with
fervor
with with zest and fervor right for like
two three hours and no one
no but a word to him at a good time he
went from his
umbrella from his seated area to the top
of the pool area
where the dj was and then at the foot of
the pool
he was doing just beautifully
choreographed dance moves i feel like i
was at a concert of his
like he was dancing we were all watching
this guy's awesome bold
yeah like there was they only let a
certain amount of people in so let's
call it 150.
those people were there at full capacity
when he was there and then
now it's hours later maybe we're at what
thirty percent capacity there was maybe
like a percent
there was maybe like by the way the only
reason we got in i want to shout her out
lucy from nashville the manager lucy
from
lucy lucy.com which is also sponsored
the company used promo hey babe if
you're looking to quit your
nicotine addiction no but danny's we're
talking about zany's lucy's
we love you zane lucy's lucy was great
she's the one who got us yeah
so we get in and then someone went out
and looked at the sign-in sheet
because they were like no there's no way
that's him because i said to other
couple of people i think that's the
emergency
people said i know who that is that's
not him and they go man i know him
pretty well i think that's him and they
went they looked at because he had to
sign in remember
i remember they went and they came back
and they go it's signed in yeah
and uh even that i felt weird about it
they were double checking
and um we're about to leave right and it
was
three hours and he was at the front of
the pool now there's only 30 people left
no one's bothering him and i'm saying
we're about to walk out if i just walk
out and just tell them
hey man i just want to let you know i'm
i'm just this huge fan of yours and
and i've seen you in concert and i just
think you're the tops right
but i know better right i'm like i
shouldn't let me leave this guy alone
but something in me
some that something in you was me
telling you you can't leave because i
said to you
i said my favorite band is the 1975.
matthew healy the lead singer in the
1975 was right there
i would have to go i'd go up and i'd i'd
hug him and i no matter what happens i'd
have to say
at least let's introduce yourself said
you know what you're right we live in
the moment we're living life who knows
when i never see him again and you did
it and it was
and as you said it was wrong it was bad
it was wrong
wrong wrong what are you saying tupper
or tubber
say the first syllable top wrong
that's what it was that's what it was
tough i went against my better judgment
and i got my bag around my way and we
were gonna walk out and i just walked to
the foot of the pool and i and i as i
approached him his couple's friends
and i think one or two of his friends
maybe maybe
recognize me or look don't i look
familiar he's no he recognized he gave
me a look of like
like that and so i thought okay no he
did it and i and i just went up to i
didn't even get too close and i just
leaned in and he was dancing
and he stopped dancing and he looked at
me and i just was like hey i don't
want to bother you at all i'm on my way
out i just want to let you know i think
you are like the greatest musician
musician on the planet and he he just
well i guess
and i said uh and uh i i've seen it in
concert multiple times
yeah i just seen him actually in philly
and he was like uh-huh
i said and i'm so sorry to bother you uh
and there's a little bit more involved
because uh he has a song that really
meant something to me personally
uh that that was what you told him and i
told him
it was this is something i'll leave out
there's a little personal but he has a
song that
really affected my life in a certain way
with a certain
instance in my life and i and i just
said that in a very clean sentence i
told him that too
and then he just was like all right and
then he kind of just was
he's well he actually said that's what's
up and then he
turned and then he turned away and and
he just like was kind of like very weary
of me
and i immediately said i'm an i'm the
[ __ ]
i should have never went up to this
person he's enjoying himself
nobody bothered him for three hours and
i was the guy
that couldn't let it go that had to tell
him what he means to me
and he hears that [ __ ] a hundred times a
day and without being cynical i get it
i get it without being cynical he didn't
need to hear from me in that instance
and i just went against my judgment i
walked out of there blaming myself
right but i will say regardless of
blaming myself
you can't walk away from something like
that without feeling a little soured
on the whole situation only since then i
feel terrible about my relationship
in my head with his music and him as a
person
the only way to get him back is you
have to now it has years have to go by
where
he's forgotten about it even you've
forgotten about it and he comes to one
of the shows
and he comes up to you and says hey you
know my kid
and i are such big fans you helped your
comedy
helped us through a major part in our
life and it was painful for us to get
through this but your comedy style your
comedy
uh got us through it and we just want to
say and i just want to say thank you and
then you go
that's what's up and then i just
continue to do the hustle then yeah and
then you slide away and you start
singing baby when we're grinding
and then you just walk away i remember
that moment i felt whenever we walked
out of there i was like
i i sounded like rayman i'm like that
was so stupid
i remember i was just like no it's okay
he forgot about it here's what i
genuinely think though let me just tell
you what i genuinely think yeah
and again this you know he's a musician
he's an entertainer whatever
i think he was high out of his mind
a legend this is
just because i there was a lot of people
smoking weed i just thought
maybe maybe maybe i maybe we connected
at the time that was not amenable to him
it's possible
uh i i was under the fault i also had
like a tinge of
no i want to say confidence maybe hope
that he he might be receptive to my
uh affection because uh we had an
exchange on twitter in the past
and he tweeted back at you but yes but
that could have just been like he's
tweeted anyone in the world but i
thought there might be a small
piece that he maybe knew who i was
because we exchanged but it was not the
case now is that the only celebrity
you've bombed
in front of like that no um
no most most no i've had some crazy
deborah harry of blondie was mean to me
one time blondie
yeah yeah blonde what's one of their
bondi is a i mean a seminal blondie it
was a band that came out of the 80s
uh i definitely heard a little side cbgb
type
punk new age uh thing where she's even
credited because
in her song uh i guess maybe it might be
rapture
she she did what was considered in the
very early stages of hip-hop
she sang of a couple of bars but because
she was this
white woman at the forefront of a
movement
she kind of uh you know just there might
be some criticism or there might be some
accolade to her for shining a light on
what was then the the nation's
stages of hip-hop right i think you can
say the nation of islam no
nation yeah yeah the early stages uh
she's uh an icon she's a fascinator she
looks like michelle pfeiffer she's she's
the best
and i don't even want to but one time i
was at a jazz concert
[Laughter]
i was at a squirrel not zippers we have
in fomo for the new york jazz festival
yeah uh in battery park okay and
i was peripherally uh
i kind of knew some of the people
slightly
slightly in this band called the
squirrel nut zippers who were having
who still are amazing but we're having a
real moment back then
and what a night i went to a lot of it's
based after candy
actually chewable hard candy squirrel
not zipper shout out and um
i saw them at this new york jazz
festival and they recognized me because
i was like a groupie of theirs that used
to go to old hunting
and um they were so nice and then um tom
maxwell
and uh and jimbo mathis and this guy
chris phillips who was the drummer
um they asked me if i wanted to come
backstage and have a beer with them and
stuff and i did and so
deborah harry was on that bill and then
i
she came up to me and i had
coincidentally
uh i was not in the public yet i had
been to a movie premiere of a movie
called six ways to sunday
that starred her and who's the guy who
did the pianist
pianist yeah adrian brody he was in it
and uh and so i was i found myself at
this nightclub called
life okay that was the night it was like
the one in page six
every week right and it was the after
party for this movie premiere and i
don't know how i got here i might have
even purchased a ticket it wasn't like
what year are we talking
oh my goodness it has to be early 2000s
okay
99 2002 something like that and i
and so i had met her i had seen her at
this nightclub after a movie
and uh and this was a very independent
movie and not many people saw it and i
thought
oh here's my in i saw six ways to sunday
i believe it was called
and uh i i'm going to tell her how
wonderful i think her music is
right and then i how great she was in
this movie right and uh
and i and and i saw it backstage and i
said mrs harry it's
such an honor to meet you uh the
performance is great tonight i've been a
fan of yours
forever obviously and six weeks to
sunday i was at the premiere and you
were amazing and she went like this to
me
and she walked away
and i i was beside myself i love it yeah
and i was like wow that was a way to
treat somebody
how do you feel if you i don't know if
she may be missing she's watching the
show now
we know she's watching debbie if you're
watching we know you all so what yeah so
i mean maybe but again maybe you just
caught somebody
how to act how to act in front of famous
people
can you read that be polite and casual
with them try not to freak out and act
different around them when then you
would anyone else's advice
celebrities will likely appreciate being
treated like regular people you can
compliment their work and tell them
you're a huge fan but try not to go
overboard like scream and cry when you
talk to them
you actually did exactly what it said to
do you followed the celebrity playbook i
mean i didn't
i really didn't even go into blondie i
just said
oh it's such an honor to meet you
because i know that she knows that i
know who she is
right i don't gotta get into like oh i
love this catalog of your music
i just said it's such an honor to meet
you i loved you in six ways to sunday
right which i thought she would be like
oh my god like i i've i've
i'm getting into acting i had this
premiere you saw this
and maybe i i just didn't even think she
would say anything i just thought she'd
be like thank you so much
right but she went
and walked away and i was like
what did you do you did you i was like a
little bit like in shock i was like
that's just that because it she did it
in front of other people
right and i just was like how do you
feel about it
i'm maybe i may be in in deep water
we have to find a way to get in touch
with her if you know blondie if she's
the equivalent of
like being like i'd love to talk to
david bowie for a moment oh you can oh
you can't just get her no
no she's a youtuber i mean not david
bowie but like
she is a an icon is she the rock and
roll hall of fame
i ibatious
is blondie it's either blondie or debbie
harry for deborah harry for
depending rock oh yeah it already comes
up oh there's a whole hall of fame
controversy
controversy okay yep uh blondie on the
second pistol
one of the six pistols i've heard of i
hope so
one of this is like the clash as far as
like the punk revolution
you know johnny you you
you know what do you know about this
experts i've just heard of the sex
pistols i've heard of the ramones
yeah yeah i mean we were going to know
blondie was one with the sex pistols
she was uh she was perfectly part of
that entire revolution yes
i the only celebrity encounter i had
really only like that
you know that was a bomb and that was
like ugh so i was
in los angeles with chas palmeteri
because i was doing a pilot for cbs
which never got on the air it's in the
toilets of cbs right now
but chaz palmitary the great actor from
a bronx tale who homeless pimp also runs
the chaz palma terry podcast check that
out check that out what's the name of it
the transparent terry show yeah i like
the chance
yeah and i love his restaurant i love
chess and by the way great food great
restaurant he's got a restaurant in
manhattan and their name of the
restaurant is chaz palminteri not chaz
palmeteris
it's chaz palmeteri he has a restaurant
named after his
his birth certificate name no his name
his name but it's not chad's palmitary's
grill
no no no no but it's not even chat no
it'd normally be like if you would have
a restaurant it'd be salvikanos
his is there's no just the name my the
name of my thing is
chaz commentary it's salvacano yeah not
south volcano it's not
the name of this establishment is sal
volcano it's jazz paletaria where is
that i want to go eat it it's in midtown
chassis is one of those people like we
mentioned didn't we mention
it was it you that was only usual
suspects yeah he
he was in the usual of course yeah
that's the whole point he said he filmed
his part
he filmed his part of the usual suspects
like a week before the like
he filmed it like in a week before like
the rest of the cast even got there like
he was like i never
he had to have that moment at the end
he's the one that dropped the mug
yeah but they he realized who kai's
associated but he did all that in in the
week before the main cast even got there
he was like so i never really even met
with any of them i mean
not to not soak up on it but i could say
i could i could
speak speak along every word to bronx
tale probably bronx says a fantastic
movie
he so he taught so chat by the way one
of the funniest things i ever saw chaz
do
is and it's just this is how you know
chance palmiero's transplantary as we
were sitting at chas
i was sitting at chas palmitari with
chaz palmitari we were eating
oh my god yeah wow
i mean what are the people are they like
when he shows up i'm sure he's the type
of guy everyone there knows him he's
there all the time he's the best
but when you're sitting at the table
right of chas palma terry with chad's
palm and terry
what does that like after chass pometary
table which is a designated table the
chat's planetary table with transparent
inside jazz momentary so it's like a
russian dolls of chess bomb terror what
is that like
it was unbelievable and i'll never you
should have sent back food well here's
what happened have fun have fun
you can you don't order you don't you
don't look at the menu which has
commentaries you say
how's the commentary the the food's just
brought out to you it's a commentary
experience you just bring out the food
so chas was wearing chaz was wearing a
black turtleneck black slacks black
shoes which is the chest prominentary
look
he he i remember for cbs he's a real
beatnik
yeah he's a real beatnik for the cbs
sitcom they had all these wardrobe
options
and he was just like listen i'm just
going to wear black turtleneck black
and that's just what it was like so it's
just chad's foundation does what he
wants i love it yeah
so he we're eating uh chicken parm
that's what they brought out and he gets
sauce
on his turtleneck and he goes maron he
goes [ __ ] i got sauce on my turtleneck
and i go ah man you know that's okay
it's going to go down to a show at the
comedy cellar and he goes like this
victor i need another neck exact quote
he goes victor i need another neck
victor
i swear puts down a plate of food that
he was either taking back or bringing to
a table
puts it down goes into the kitchen area
comes out with a turtleneck on a hanger
gives him the
identical turtleneck he's wearing give
it to him chaz goes i'll be right back
comes out a man right now that i feel
like i need to have a relationship with
you well you will have a relationship
with chad
i love that no chad partier is going to
be a guest on him i get along with
chad's palmetto 5 000
you get along with chase chad's
momentary i feel like i would i'm an old
soul
no so not that he's old i just mean like
he's old school he's old school yeah so
chas palmeteri we're sitting down
this is so that that's just a quick jazz
puppeteer story but the celebrity
encounter cause challenge is obviously a
massive celebrity and by the way the
first time when we cast it for the pilot
was fantastic i want to go to dinner
with chaz and elon musk and me and you
and you and i think we'll all get along
we're going to talk about bronx tail and
bitcoin that's what we'll do
babes yep we are in the thick of 2020's
ugly sequel and guess what life can
still be stressful as f
yeah i mean if you're feeling that
existential dread whenever you have a
couple of minutes of downtime
you might be experiencing those scary
luckily our partners at sunday scaries
make the best f and c we need products
to turn those wtfs into lols
forget about an old awkward date or that
time you responded to a server telling
you to enjoy your meal
with a good old you too sunday scaries
is here to provide you the remedy to
make life not so scary their cbd gummies
are so perfect
they're the perfect product to help you
kick back and chill the f
out they even added vitamins b12 and d3
to get that extra boost of vitamin
goodness to give you the perfect blend
to make you more tolerable to co-workers
and friends
babe can i ask you a question yeah you
vegan no
sunday scaries even has vegan gummies
called vegan af
that are the guilt-free version of cbd
you've been kindly hunting
to help you forget about becky's
showboat ig
account don't get shook in 2021
get 20 off at sundayscaries.com and use
the promo code hey babe
20 off at sundayscares.com with promo
code hey baby it's 20
off at sundayscaries.com with the promo
code hey babe thanks
sunday scaries for making sundays chill
again
what do you think trick question i don't
think
more than 50 million men in the united
states you know what they suffer from
i'm gonna give you the initials mpb
m-m-p-p-b
yep michael peanut butter
nope okay male pattern baldness okay
same
male pattern baldness and guess what
yeah there's actually
what when i when i this morning i woke
up
first thing i said to my mother my
mother stepped over first thing i said
to her i said mom there's got to be at
least five fda recommended
products for male pattern baldness she
said i would say more than that honey
guess what only two there are only two
fda approved medications that prevent
hair loss you know what one of them is
you know he keeps they don't
no that's not the medication keeps
offers both
of the two fda approved medications yeah
you ruined the whole thing
oh i'm sorry no no we're going to keep
going
we're going to keep this in okay yeah
well
capes convenient virtual doctor
consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months you don't
have to leave your home you don't have
to leave your home
guess what what you know what whenever
this episode comes out yeah
it's probably going to come out
somewhere soon yeah around easter
time yeah guess what baby you're not
getting peeps this year
you're getting keeps that's what you get
what you got to do all you got to do if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss now
all you got to do is go to keeps
k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash hey babe
to receive your to receive your first
month of treatment
for free what is it sal tell them again
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash hey babe
to get your first month free k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash hey babe
you know when you go online okay and you
just you're home alone
right and you're searching for
everything that you want under the sun
yes
you know that people can see that even
if you're in incognito mode
i don't know what you're searching for
right but you know that they're tracking
everything that's how you get
personalized ads
and it's one of those things where it's
like it's just something that i've i've
accepted in my life that when i do stuff
like that people can see it and
my ads will be sold and there's really
nothing absolutely nothing i can do
about it and it's just a sad cruel world
it sounds like what we were implicating
with that you go online and look up
illegal things
that's not what i meant oh i meant that
you're being tracked all the time your
information your data is being sold
all the time right and i can't stop that
well you can actually with expressvpn i
can't
no you can expressvpn i have i have this
even before they were on our show i've
had this for two three years now on my
computer and my phone wait a second so
you're telling me if i go to
expressvpn.com
yeah and i go into the incognito mode no
no i don't even have to do that
that's not it look protect your online
activity
protect your online activity today with
the vpn rated number one by cnet which
is like
they're the end all be all sure you're
talking tech right they should be called
and wired even those the two big dogs
visit uh our exclusive link
expressvpn.com
hey babe and you get an extra three
months free on a one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
hey babe expressvpn.com
to learn more do you wanna do you know
what we're doing right now
did you get that i know exactly what
we're doing but i want to know if they
can retroactively
wipe out because i looked at some stuff
yesterday
that you're gonna have to contact the
company directly okay and you might have
to pay an extra fee
and i cannot really say yes or no
whether they could do it but they can
absolutely do it
so just go to express expressvpn.com hey
babe i got three months off a full year
package
nobody knows what i'm googling you can't
see my ads and that's what it is
it's available on all your devices it's
uh it's it's it's
you can put it on your smart television
it runs seamlessly in the background you
tap the one button you turn it on
and you're protected and in this day and
age everyone can use
a bit more protection can we not we can
expressvpn.com
hey babe go do it right now and we won't
know you did it because it blocked out
your data
the buffy comforter i can't say enough
about the buffy comforter my
girlfriend's pregnant right now
she literally she this is her third
child she's saying
that this pregnancy is getting easier
and easier every day
since we got the buffy um dude i'm
telling you she used to night sweat you
have to understand how much used to
knights went i mean it would be like
literally somebody took her in the
middle and i threw in her pool
and then put her back in the bed no more
night sweats because the breeze buffy
regulates the temperature and for all
you vegans out there
it's 100 plant-based design wow
it's made of eucalyptus fabric inside
and out it's softer than cotton
it naturally suits the skin it's earth
friendly it's hypoallergenic
it's cruelty free it brings i'm telling
you this is crazy
full of eucalyptus debris don't let it
near a koala bear
you can try a comforter in your own bed
for free not sal because i haven't sent
to one yet they're sending it to me
if you don't love it you return it at no
cost let me tell you something right
freaking now
buffy if you're just gonna scroll down a
little bit pippi buffy
is one of those things where i'm telling
you it got sent to the house at first i
was like what is this the buffy because
you're thinking buffy the vampire slayer
you're thinking
what does buffy mean and then it it's
this beautiful bedding i put it down i
took a three-hour nap
my kid was walking around the house my
five-year-old she turned on the oven i
had no idea because i'm asleep on the
back are you serious sleep on the buffy
i go to buffy chickens at first right
nope from my old neighborhood
okay here we go if you go to buffy.com
because listen to me a company like
buffy doesn't have time to put the n
m in yeah it's buffy dot co and you
enter hey babe
that's h-e-y-b-a-b you ready for this
yeah
twenty dollars off twenty dollars for a
spanish-speaking audience
vente dollars yeah that's it andrew
jackson
buffy.com without the m buffy dot co
enter hey babe h-e-y-b-a-b-e
twenty dollars off it's unbelievable sal
doesn't know what i'm talking about
because he didn't get the buffy
i did chase commentary first time i met
him in los angeles after we hired him
for the pilot in new york city
he's walking on the treadmill at 3.5
miles per hour
full fila velour sweatsuit sunglasses
and dress shoes
walking at 3.5 he goes this is what i do
every day for an hour with the dress
because he says he goes a lot of people
ask me what my secret is to stay in
shape all these years
he goes it's right here kid and then he
just pointed to his outfit his shoes his
glasses and 3.5 on the tread
so that's that's 3.5 2.5 miles per hour
on the treadmill he would walk
he walks for an hour 3.5 miles per hour
on the treadmill looking straight up
no book no book no music in a in like a
a fila
like or like a you know dress shoes with
dress shoes on and sunglasses
with a leather upper sunglasses on
inside we're an indoor gym in the hotel
sunglasses on
the show paves his own road that's what
it is he's got a driver
transplantary never drives his own car
he sits in the back seat of the cars he
has somebody else
it's just chaz's chas it's a 10 out of
10. i can't explain too much i love
chess commentary magnus not even to
deviate but for one second speaking
about a guy who paid his own road shout
out tom brady
shout out tom brady super bowl with the
bucks god bless him
but i will find the nfl i also just want
to say also but i also just want to say
congratulations to the kansas city
chiefs
second place you cannot tip the hat but
not not tip the hat so chad's palmitary
where enlarges his real name then
cologial was his real name oh named it
to c yeah the closure though is his real
name from bronx tales yeah that's it
collage though yeah
and by the way is chas
universally a short and collogiato or is
he chas
independently of the name collaboration
no that's a good question but i mean is
there a better name than jazz
i see a better name in collegiate or
palm and terry i don't think so chaz
yeah and
and and you know his is uh you know been
to his house
uh many times for dinner beautiful i
mean the the palmetto shout out to
commentary whole planetary family i mean
10 out of 10 greatest people
great cooks i mean the commentary just
hospitable i can't explain to you
how much my family loves pomegranates
cannot wait until i break bread with
chess palmitary
putting it out into the universe oh it's
going to like the book the secret
but i read articles about it look at
this going back to the year look at the
years active for chad's parliamentaries
wikipedia in 1984 the president
came came on the scene in 84. the day
you were born
26 1984. lorenzo commentary may 15 1952.
um so chaz so we're in we're in
we're in catch in los angeles very
trendy upscale restaurant in la
in 2016-ish 2017 when i'm doing the cbs
pilot chad's playing my dad annie potts
playing my mom
diane guerrero from orange is the new
black playing my wife fantastic
actress dina maria uh rivas who's who's
who's
up i think she's up for an award now um
i i think a golden globe or something
did you shoot
actress you posted the pilot right i did
did they ever take it down they did not
so direct people to the pilot
go on my instagram or my youtube
youtube.com christy comedy my full cbs
pilot
is up there i'm wearing cargo pants and
a sweatshirt and it's just are you an
islanders jersey i was in an island new
jersey at one point
was created co-created by you know it
was off based off my comedy but also
everything because raymond know how i
met your mother how about you craig
thomas at carter base
so there's chad's with a hairpiece uh
chas yeah
so and the great diane guerrero so so
anyway so we're doing so we're hanging
out
so we're hanging out in this uh in catch
la me chaz palmitaria and chaz's friend
sunny who i just will keep it there
sure so sunny it's just a friend for the
neighborhood great guy
sunny he literally looks like he's made
of italian steel
sunny just a guy that let's just say
when you're when chazz is with sunny
you're not going to get too close to
chas
if if if you know if sonny was next to
leon bridges that day
yeah you would have been back in the
pool you know what i mean he would have
thrown you in the pool that's fun
it's fun to be like i got a guy yeah i
mean
i just filmed him giving me a tour of
the bronx for youtube yeah
and the the people he rolls with are
unbelievable birth control control
and also it's the most i've ever seen
people with face tattoos cry meeting
somebody
yeah everybody who's chat dude chaz is
one of those guys man where like when
you go out with chaz palmitari
you don't even you know like somebody's
pr agent would call ahead like
somebody's pr agent would call it
it's basically like bitcoin chaz is
bitcoin he's done a lot of good but some
of the stuff he's put out there like two
percent of it
is not good not good but but we'll just
we won't talk about that part that's
what it is
yeah so chad so so when chas shows up at
like if like a restaurant or like a
nightclub is like packed and there's a
line out the door yeah there's no
pr call ahead chaz just walks up to the
security guard and they give they face
they recognize who he is and they open
the thing
and they better to be loved or feared
and that's what it is and they never say
welcome son they never say welcome chad
so he's welcome sonny they just he they
call him
no he is called by his character name
wherever he goes that's what it is
sonny had five fingers but he only used
three that's what it is
i mean the behind the scenes by the way
i mean go listen to the chest voluntary
podcast because it gets into a lot of us
but i mean the behind the scenes stories
that i was told
by chaz of riding a bronx tale and
coming up with
you know the door test and all these
iconic movies
like he would talk to me like like we're
doing right now like it's so
so i'm sitting with chas me chaz and
sunny we're in catch
chat two three just us three right now
catch i love that it's great
catch la great place we're in the corner
you know chad gets a corner table of
course
they two things happen when chaz walks
into a place they give him the corner
table and i guess people just know this
they bring him out of shrimp cocktail
tower
that's how it works wow so they came out
with the shrimp cocktail they said here
you go gumbo
of course come on commentary yeah so
so all with that we're having a great
time i bet you he doesn't even
bet you eat jumbo shrimp like it's
nothing like it's nothing like it's
popcorn
yeah joelle embiid from the philadelphia
76ers walks in on one side sure
yeah and he just says you know literally
makes he goes
sunny love you love you sonny and then
chas says without even missing a beat
while he's eating a shrimp cocktail he
goes trust the process
trust the process is joel embiid's
slogan your
chaz knew yes the slogan and hit him
back with it
like that immediately how cool do you
have to be
yeah to have someone be like i mean
that's the coolest interaction i've ever
heard in my enzyme
he's just caught because joel i mean
joel you witnessed it i was right there
joel embiid came over
and he said he said i'm such a big fan
sonny i i love
i love all your work and he goes trust
the process you didn't you didn't hand
chas a napkin under the table it's
addressed the process no challenge no
chat chad's one of those guys he doesn't
even really drink he'll hang out to
eight o'clock in the morning
all day ever he'll hang out i need to i
need to meet chess so
i need to i need to meet you i need to
have like a seven hour meal with has
that spans from
yeah a cold andy pass to a hundred past
to a salad to a pasta to a meat
to a dessert to a coffee to then just
after dinner drinks to lemoncello
so they're flashing the lights literally
to have that night with chas
where we talk about everything and when
we come out of that experience it jumps
us it leaps frogs us like three years i
would say
if you're watching the universe like the
secret i've never read the secret but
i've read articles about the secret
i'm gonna tell you this right now and
and and you could back me up on this
pimp
if you want the chas pomentary connect i
don't think there's a better connect
than me and homeless pimp you don't
think we are the connection to chaz
palmitary i will bring him some pignoli
and some fresh mozzarella
and i'll i'll go i'll bring some nice a
nice dish to his house
maybe a beautiful bottle of wine and i
will i will introduce
i will introduce myself and then i just
would love to talk to him about times
past 100 he's going to do it
by the way transplanted's got the
greatest wine cellar and i mean he's got
full paintings of italy he's got he'll
take that i'll put it right in the wine
cellar let's do it as a frolic session
for the patreon for hey babe coming out
soon there you go
so here we go so we're sitting at
catcher like joel and b comes in trust
the process bang that's what happens
all of a sudden there's a lot of
commotion on the other side of the
restaurant almost to the point where i
thought there was a fight i was like oh
you know
and you know sonny even thought there
was a fight because you i could tell he
like looked up like he's like a human
pitbull he looked up
and i was like okay anybody gets even
close to chaz everyone's gonna die i was
gonna be used as a human shield and
that's just what it is i'm you know
it's just arbitrary you know by the way
be honest for that role yeah
yeah that's what it is they always talk
transplantary who talks about he always
picks out a guy in the restaurant oh
yeah this guy's the first to go well he
said that guy's the first to go
like he'll look around back look at this
guy he's the first to go so i know at
that point i was the first to go yeah
yeah that's going to be a little hang
over your head a little bit yeah yeah
when you're like
when you're like when you all meet up
and the whole party is there and you
look and you do a check and you're like
oh i'm the first i'm the first to go
here
says this guy's the first to go it's
great you're getting you're getting the
bullets in the chest
yeah so there's so there's a there's all
this commotion in the front i said what
the hell what's going on
sonny looks over even tras looks over
still in the shrimp cocktail i look over
it's leonardo dicaprio leonardo dicaprio
tell me he comes over and pays respects
please
are you kidding me wait a minute yes
your balls got blown off they grew back
unfortunately one of these days they're
not gonna go back
i hope you have insurance on them cause
ball's gonna get blown off yeah it's
leno dicaprio
leonardo dicaprio's girlfriend at the
time uh the kid from spider-man
told for um uh topher grace the kid from
toby maguire toby mcguire that's who it
is toby mcguire the kid from spider-man
toby mcguire and two or three other
people from spider-man aka he is
spider-man he's spider-man yeah
yeah yeah so is that the same person the
spider-man kid yeah
seabiscuit yeah toby because they were a
crew dicaprio yeah yeah they they were
always going to
they were page six out yes uh here's one
about tell you yeah toby mcguire the
spider-man kid
leonardo's girlfriend who's a sport
mcguire's he's not the spider-man kid
put some respect on mcguire's name i'm
gonna put some spider-man
he's not you know so i don't know where
he's been
right but he probably made his fortune
and now he's just having a great day
he's having a great day yeah yeah so
he's
he used to roll leonardo dicaprio's
girlfriend at the time who is a sports
illustrated supermodel named nina ogdahl
who i actually did
uh guy code with she was on the season
of guy code when i was on guy called
she walked in and you had already done
so you had to connect with this girl all
right
and then continue so here we go so it's
on mtv2
so leonardo dicaprio comes over he's on
the he's on the other s
he's on the other side of the restaurant
wait before you continue
the show was on ntv2 uh guy called on
him yeah
so so chat not mtv mtv2 sure so
chaz with that says he goes oh i know
leo he goes to be honest with you guys i
know leo sits before he was anybody
he goes i told leo he goes i told leo
when he was just a kid i said listen kid
this is a game of interest
it's only going to be a millimeter on
why you're going to be a star and
somebody else ain't he goes always
remember that
so i'm like wow that's crazy right
whatever tell me leonardo carver comes
over and was like
chad hey guys i'll do it hey gets a game
of inches and walks away
tell me he echoes the sentiments here's
what i'm about tell you leonardo
dicaprio also has
bodyguards of course he has bodyguards
leonardo dicaprio yeah
you know cabrio's dad no peculiar guy
interesting
river very has a very uh specific look
to him
uh maybe it's not as real dude he just
texted me last week and he goes
no joke hold on hold on george dicaprio
shout out george dicaprio
casey
[Music]
seven days ago he goes have you ever
seen a photo of leo dicaprio's dad
you're right no he goes give it a google
it's a fun one
you go what's with that blazer but naked
underneath and he goes and part of it is
tied around her waist very confusing
something else oh sorry about that edit
that part out
but yeah so i was just talking about
leonardo gabriel's dad
yeah yeah tim that's him so leonardo
continue now okay
so leo dicaprio without his father yeah
he's in the restaurant he's goes
gets up to go use the bathroom you're
chomping on shrimp [ __ ]
we're eating shrimp [ __ ] we're eating
trim [ __ ] you can't imagine i am
literally deep throwing trim [ __ ] yeah
so
so he's the bathroom is is not that far
from the table
so chaz you know again at the top of his
lungs
leo's leonardo dicaprio like we were
like everybody was like you can't go by
leo's table there's security guards it's
leonardo dicaprio he's arguably the most
famous person in all of hollywood
leo is walking towards the bathroom with
the security guard chaz goes
leo get the over here
wow i swear to god wow leo looks and i
know you're at chad's palm and terry
no we're strong catch l.a oh yeah that's
my bed now
leo again i mean he must hear stuff like
that all the time right
the security guard looks up you know
because leo didn't look up time
whisper something to leonardo dicaprio i
would imagine saying i believe that's
chaz palmitari
leo literally looks up like a 10 year
old boy
and goes cheers cheers
i swear to god goes are you are you here
are you gonna be here for a little bit
longer like a kid chaz goes of course we
just sat down
he goes let me just go to the bathroom
let me go to the bathroom whisper some
of the security guards here with that
the table that toby mcguire the
spider-man kid
nina ogdahl his sports illustrated
waitress and the other people were there
that table gets lifted up gets connected
to our table no
yes uh what yes are you like neon doll
yeah here's what happens yeah leo
dicaprio comes out of the bathroom
which is all done he comes back down
sits down of course next to chaz the
only time by the way shout out to leo
for going to the bathroom a piss because
that guy got pissed anywhere he could
piss anywhere could have pissed
he could have pissed him my shrimp
cocktail i still would have eaten that
right in the shrimp [ __ ] he could have
peed
in a shrimp [ __ ] you would have ate it
and said can i have more 100 it's a
golden shrimp
tower yes so so with that he sits down
leonardo dicaprio i'm
so now it's sonny gets up moves to one
side leon the capital of course at the
head of this this new form table sure
chas palm and terry and then i was
sitting next to chad there was no reason
for me to move nina ogdell directly
across from me
because she's sitting next to leo so leo
says to chaz he goes i haven't seen you
in so long
because i just want to say thanks so
much for all the advice she gave me
coming up
and then chas looks at me and goes the
game of interest do you remember the
game eventually goes of course he goes
and thank you for telling martin
scorsese to take a chance on me
chaz had told scorsese hey leonardo
caprio is a really great actor
and kind of chas and you told chaz you
know
chaz told martin scorsese i really think
you should bet on leon dicaprio at that
time leonardo dicaprio was [ __ ]
bitcoin nobody knew who he was going to
be
so leonardo dicaprio remembers chaz and
i'm telling you looked up to chad's
looked after chaz like like a 10 year
old boy with that
chaz says he goes who's your friend to
tony maguire he goes oh he's in
spider-man he goes spidey
love this kid that's why i kept calling
the spider-man kid because i
i was like he called him spidey only
jazz could do this
and toby mcguire starts laughing he goes
i spied spider goes love this kid
he tells the way he goes we need more
shrimp cocktail for spidey
he keeps calling them spidey and they're
loving it so we're having today
we're having a good time nina ogdahl you
know and you know they're all talking
whatever telling stories they know the
capital is the most down-to-earth guy
i mean it's unbelievable what a nice guy
this is sure this is chazz is telling
hilarious stories sonny's laughing
with that i did you ever get past the
conch
did you ever get to tell a story to
everybody here's what happened
because this whole thing started with
celebrity bombs
what happened was is again i'm kind of
sitting there nervous
i don't really know what to say i'm very
out of place oh you're bombed
oh my god even right now i don't want to
hear this so so
so your fate your body so nina i start
talking to nina ogdahl
i started do you know who i know did she
did she
reciprocate that she knew you i said i
said hey nina i don't know if you
remember me and i could tell she did not
she was like
very polite and sweet i was like i don't
know if you remember me but we worked
together on guy code and she you know
she's from like
denmark's and she's like oh yeah ah yes
yeah yeah hi hi and i was like oh that's
nice you know like whatever
she didn't remember me yeah so then
we're talk i'm like how are things
whatever and she's like oh good you know
i did cover sports illustrated or
whatever and i'm like oh yeah i'll be at
bananas in hashbrown
new jersey i got you know i you know you
know i'm like
you know she she's like so so
i got a i got a deal on uh groupon right
now
yes oh my gosh living social my living
social deal is going
well going well so so i'm like you know
so we're talking yeah
about you know for a minute then leon
dicaprio
looks at me and i say to leonardo
dicaprio
i go oh leo no it's all good i was just
we worked together on mtv too we worked
together on
mtv2 so that's why we're talking and he
goes
buddy it's okay you can talk to her he
goes you worked with her on mtv2
that's sweet and then chas goes he goes
why the would you announce that you
worked with nina
with his girlfriend on mtv2
he goes do you think he's threatened by
you because you guys worked on
mtv2 he goes tables rock
die i mean spidey is dying i always be
like spider-man listen you little
i'll go kick he goes really quick
he goes mtv too he goes this guy just
won a
an oscar he goes because he had just one
for the revenant
he goes he just yeah yeah he was
enjoying the revenue
he goes this guy just won the oscar he
goes do you think he's worried about you
working with her from mtv2
and then and then leo goes he goes yeah
chris he goes which is
pretty cool that he remembered my name
he was like yeah chris he goes that's
fine he goes you can talk about mtv2 to
her
all night long he's so funny
so funny so funny then we go because you
kind of ingratiate
with that he ingratiated like it was
kind of like a breaking of the eyes well
it was it wasn't it wasn't because i
mean nina did not say a
single word to me for the rest of the
night wow
yeah i mean i mean it's just like you
know well she's now talking to leo sure
and it's just like whatever
so it wasn't awkward it was oh no it was
all fun and then and then you really see
like famous famous so then like
because you know chad's is very famous
and whatever so we go downstairs
with leo's one of those things it's like
it's like there's levels and even chad
said there's like levels of fame like
it's
crazy like there's doors that open up on
doors yeah so we go down through a
private back door
to get to retrieve sonny and chaz's car
through a private back door to get to
the
like garage which there's like parking
spaces in the garage but then there's
like a garage inside of a garage
that you know where chas is cars like
that so we're like oh whatever get out
all of a sudden we see an elevator open
which was like you know a freight
elevator that didn't think
no cars would be in and out of all of a
sudden a platform a platform comes up
there's a 2017 maserati there chad the
leonardo dicaprio comes out of a
back door behind a back door with his
entourage they're getting the maserati
how sub-level the garage is right and
how many back doors to the back door
you're allowed to walk through yeah yeah
no that's so that was the time when like
the major celebrity but i got to be
honest with you
leonardo dicaprio he couldn't have been
nicer and more down to earth and like i
couldn't believe a guy is famous as him
and it's just a beautiful thing
a guy as big as him and as revered as
him to be as cool as he was
yeah like really just a cool guy yeah i
think that's the secret
like when you get that big you got to
stay low you got to say level man he was
great but that was like my time with
everyone you mentioned i feel like i
really would get along with dude i'm
telling you i know
you know you know i know people like fat
joe i know
fat joe i could text fat joe right now
like i know people
actually this show i did the mlb um oh
by you want to talk
you want to talk about another quick
story i'm sorry that this one's we've
been calling about me we came here to do
this that's why we're doing the show
right yeah
so i'm wearing the sweatshirt whole
adventure is about this 2014 mlb
all-star game i hosted a show
on mlb uh on the mlm off the bat
it was mlb and mtv2 they tried to mlb
wanted to make their audience younger so
they said let's team up with
people from mtv2 they put the show on
sundays at 11am it's like that's not
necessarily the best time frame but what
can you do that's what can you do yeah
it's pretty young
it's morning cartoons you're off the bat
the demo was ages two to five ages two
to five so the hosts of this show are
uh sway from swain in the morning the
great the great sway callaway
i mean radio legend icon is five fingers
of death
five figures death interval interview
tupac and biggie yeah and
president obama four times actually um i
was supposed to
we got a we got offered to go on sway
recently
and i think that joe and murr took that
and it's really funny to me that murrah
was on sway in the morning
i really hope he did okay
because you know because sway i i want
to i would want to impress sway sway
so sway great i mean literally taught me
like so many things like sway is just
like i can't say enough positive things
oh great sway is just a great guy with
again unbelievable stories i mean
tupac big he interviewed barack obama
four times president obama
like just like like literally sweat
obama will call sway on his private
phone that's crazy that's
like that's how it is i get something
you ever hear tell stories sometimes
cypher sounds like he's at the like
nexus
yeah of like seminal moments oh yeah in
hip-hop and it's like
and he's got pictures to prove it yeah
and then we're just eating like a slice
of sicilian pizza yeah at 4am on a
tuesday together
yeah you give you these stories but
continue please so so so the hosts so
the hosts are
sway number one um uh
fat joe greatest rap you know great
rapper uh bronx icon fat joe
melanie iglesias another uh uh model
from also mtv2 sky code and
maxum model and then me i have a fat joe
story continue
so oh fat i mean literally we could do
fat show stories for another pot like a
whole podcast of fat joe stories like
facho is the man he told me he lost 150
pounds by just drinking black cherry
seltzers that's all he changed in his
diet
he said i went for black cherry he said
i used to drink sodas and i'll do black
cherry salsas i'm 150 down boy
i was like okay so crazy diet so it's
crazy diet
zero calories zero cows so greatest guy
fat joe
but so we're doing the show we're doing
we're doing um
uh the off the bat show and then part of
the thing you know
you know because it's all in with mlb
and mlb wants tomorrow out there and
show
the mlb all-star game comes along in
july of 2014
in minneapolis minnesota target field
you're in it i mean it playing in the
celebrity softball game
because me melanie glaciers fat joe and
sway all got to play in the celebrity
softball game right
so a couple of things happen one we're
in minneapolis minnesota at the time
adrian peterson was the star running
back of the minnesota vikings
and i mean absolute double threat
couldn't
imagine how great of a guy he was a
receiving running back
so it was age in the lineup he was
number one pick for everyone
they they announced they announced in
the lineup
that you know they they had us all line
up on the third base line we were on the
third base line and they announced to
the crowd of 40 000 people
each individual player and we would step
forward and get applause breaks
right so it's adrian peterson me
then a man who lost both all four of his
limbs
in the war right who was playing so
you're in a good position
right right i am now i'm i'm the i'm the
fourth lead
i'm the fourth leading host of a show on
mtv2 that's on sunday mornings at 11 a.m
eastern time
adrian peterson steps up you could it
was it was as if those planes flew over
the stadium blue angels cro it's adrian
peterson
adrian adrian
i stepped forward i swear to god you
told me this
the only well this because it happened
to me with phil collins too okay with
the knicks
the only person i heard the only person
i heard was my father
all i heard was my phone my father was i
heard my father clapping
and my friend pat finnegan patty fly
balls who was there i could see him
with his cell phone recording the whole
thing are you on wizard field
uh uh target field in minnesota
minneapolis
the next guy goes up the man you know
who lost all his limbs in the war
people are actually weeping and crying
for him of course as they should be
so i was like okay i mean this i'm you
know bomb this is bad whatever
it's a softball game okay i don't get
put in the starting lineup john smalls
greatest great
hall of fame atlanta hall of fame
atlanta braves pitcher is the head coach
jenny finch is also on my team jenny
finch who's the uh
iconic united states like gold gold
medal winning softball
softball player ricky henderson yep
ricky henderson andre dawson the hawk
mike piazza
uh um uh who else so many ozzie smith
the wizard oh my gosh
yes all on my team these guys are all on
my team yeah uh larry fitzsimmons the
the the running uh the wide receiver for
the arizona cardinals i hate him
hey why i'm joking it's larry fitzgerald
larry fitzgerald what i meant to say i'm
sorry i i i mixed up
who's the community greg simmons
charlotte you can easily get them either
simmons is the larry fitzgerald of
comedy absolutely hall of famer
so i don't start then i say they
they they uh you know i pinch hit i come
in
with the softball game you could pinch
it and then you could go back go into
the field yeah there's no rules whatever
so i go up it's softball
the first pitch i i um i'm up against uh
i forgot who
who was kevin millar was the catcher
behind me was actually really cool he
was he was the catcher and then the
picture was
he used to be on the twins jack
something i forgot what his name was he
was a pigeons
he was on the twins he won the world
series i'm forgetting what his name was
my father like
he was their ace he was he was their
race but he was the softball pitcher
i'm just forgetting what his name was
what year was he like in the 80s
but but they won the world series first
batter up i pop up to the catcher
and then kevin millar texts me and he
goes ooh that was rough but you know
whatever he said he was like ooh
whatever so then i go into the outfield
i'm in the outfield they give me as a
goof they give me this humongous glove
like a way oversized glove i think if
you who chris distefano mlb all-star
game over size glove
i'm standing in left field with this
oversized humongous glove
somebody hits a pop-up to me it hits me
in the face
so now yeah so now i've popped up to the
catcher i've been hit in the face with
the softball in front of 40 000 people
and even melanie iglesias got a hit and
got on base
no so now so now i'm up for the second
you mean it was a comically oversized
club comically
like they were like we're gonna make
this playful right what do you just mean
they gave you a glove that happened to
be way too big for you
no it was like a comically oversized
glove yeah because i'm like i'm a
comedian it'll be funny
it by the way bob i was like look at
this glove guys and andre dawson and
john smalls were like this is not funny
just like we take this stuff seriously
we're professional baseball players
also nelly was on my team who won the
mvp of the game he's a fantastic player
i think he had four home runs really yes
nelly was on my team
band-aid or no band-aid uh i think
band-aid nelly by the way shout-out
nelly just sold his mansion um i saw
that it was or
at least it's listed it's listed but he
got a buyer so congrats no
i would i would have been able i would
have been able to do it but i sold a
bitcoin so
so nelly so so i go up again then the
second time i go up i strike out
okay now i'm over two third time i go up
i pop out again to the couch or get
tagged out again
so with that who said right now yeah
goose egg it's horrible
my dad is we get back on the team bus
we're back on the team bus
like literally going with my team back
to the hotel which is like a five minute
drive
my dad is on the bus with us it is me my
father
ricky henderson ozzy smith and andre
dawson
sitting in the bus andre dawson says
you know to me he goes man you had a
rough day at the plate
wow that starts laughing and then dawson
my dad turns around and says to andre
dawson ricky henderson and ozzy smith
he goes i'm embarrassed the guy he
should take his he goes on his father he
goes
i'm embarrassed i'm telling he should
burn that jersey and ricky henderson
says in the third person because that's
how ricky talks he goes
ricky would burn that jersey too i swear
to god then ozzy rookie likes his
chicken spicy sal for the
for the entirety of this five-minute
drive which felt like 45 minutes
ricky henderson andre dawson ozzie smith
and my father are abusing me roasting me
making fun of me
to the point where they were getting the
laughs so high
they were killing with this ozzy smith
my father and daryl strawberry went out
for coffee the next morning
because ozzy smith told daryl strawberry
who was also on my team but wasn't a
part of this thing
how much fun they were having with and i
think to this day my father and ozzy
smith are still friends
yeah all for me going overseas so the
more of the story is to hear kids
sometimes when you suck good things
happen
wow i mean that's some life when you're
on your your db
yeah deathbed that's right not to bring
everything man but that's gonna flash
and that moment will flash in front of
you
it was one of those moments where i'm
like i'm so happy my dad and and my and
my
close friends were there to witness it
because i mean it was like it was and
then i forget about it i mean i saw
things
where it's like i saw i saw the former
al mvp at five o'clock in the morning
drunk off his face in the streets of
minneapolis eating pizza
all-star game started in 10 more hours
he hit two home runs
so it just shows like that people are
like david wells like yeah like how good
how good these athletes are yeah you
know so that was that was probably one
of the coolest moments of my life
it's 2014 to be involved with the major
leagues but i mean literally ricky
henderson was roasting me in the third
person
he said ricky would burn the jersey he
kept and then he said to me he said
ricky would have kept his weight on his
back foot
ricky noticed you didn't have your
weight on your back foot wow i swear and
it was like great
oh man we should talk about ourselves in
the third yeah it was great
that's fun yeah fat joe one time he was
playing the wave here on staten island
okay on wave street it was called the
junkyard or the wave it was the wave for
many years
and he came to do a show and it was like
93-ish
right and we went down and it was like i
guess it was all ages night unless i was
93 i wouldn't have been no nine maybe it
was more like 90 it was college we were
like 96
i don't know if i had a fake idea was 18
to 21 to drink right i was in there
and um the place was packed to see he
had like a bunch of hits at that time
that joe was big
and he wasn't coming on he wasn't coming
on he wasn't coming on it was getting
really late and people were getting
restless
and then everyone was like yo what's
going on then someone from his camp came
on he's like hey yo
fat joe has the flu okay he has the flu
he's not feeling well
but he's gonna come out right now for
you he he could
not he could have canceled tonight but
he's gonna come out and sing a song or
two
just for you guys okay but he has the
flu so that's all he's doing and we're
leaving
and then everyone just starts a booing
and booing right
could you imagine if that was 20 21 i
mean they would evacuate the building
that would have been like a terrorist
threat to come out with the flu
fat fat joe has symptoms yes
so um so everyone just starts booing and
you know it's like a lot of people there
like i'm just a kid there but there's
like
people like yelling and facho came out
and he's like yo i'm gonna just i'm not
feeling well i'm gonna sing a couple
songs for you guys i'm out of here or
rap or whatever
and then everyone just starts spooking
then he doesn't take kyle into it he's
like yo
what are you you're booing me and then
fat joe goes on a tear in his camp
i'm not sure if it was fat joe or he
left or
his cam i forgot who said this but
they're like yo you know what
call y'all they're like staten island
will be nothing
without the wu-tang clan you'd be
nothing i wouldn't even come through
here
and then that got everyone nuts and then
people started screaming
and then people just started throwing
[ __ ] at the stage and then they were
like
you and they just dropped the mics and
they all left really yeah
yeah i was there you saw that i watched
it
i was on stage with fat joe at bb kings
in 2015 it was actually the very first
date i went on with
jasmine who's my children's mother my
girlfriend
she that our very first date was in 2000
i'm sorry 2014 at bb kings we took her
to a fat joe concert so still doing the
show
fat joe brought me up on stage asked me
to tell a couple of jokes i was like
it's a bat
i swear no yeah doesn't understand yeah
i said he doesn't understand i was like
joe joe joe
i was like i was like such a bad idea
like he's like i will just rock with me
then so we start dancing he starts
singing lean back and his shoe breaks
i swear he got his foot his foot came
out of the heel of the shoe
he takes up seat goes yo chris throw my
shoe into the crowd
jasmine may have footage of this i threw
fat joe's
green room and like he was like busy he
was like nah in time and she's like well
you look like an easter egg anyway
and walked away i was like oh my god no
i swear to god but she didn't hear it he
didn't hear it
but she but she said that she's like you
look like an easter egg anyway
[ __ ] escalated quickly
well that's how jasmine is that's
uh god forbid fat joe heard jazz call
him an easter egg
how would that have gone over i don't
know what would that have done to your
job right off the bat
probably not good probably wouldn't have
went well that's acting fast and loose
with people who are a little bit
had a bigger position than you at this
at the work in the workplace
yeah well it would go corn fat joe and
easter egg
to be to be fair he was wearing a light
blue powdered velour
sweatshirt so it wasn't so much about
fat joe as it was about his colossal
it was he would look the easter egg but
yeah fat shout out fat joe i love fat
joe
you look like an easter egg it's more
just because he was wearing pastels
anybody
because not by the way he's not even fat
no dude he's skinny minnie joe
skinny minnie joe voucher so great i
mean one of the truly like one of the
most awesome guys we talked about
recently how i sat next to him courtside
of the nick games yeah it's great with
matthew broderick a magic broadway son
yeah yeah yeah it's just shout out to
or maybe it's on an episode you guys
haven't heard yet we don't know what
pimp's going to do we don't know i
honestly think we talked about this game
at some point but there's one or two
reps in the pocket that we might have
discussed and by the way if that ever
happens
with a grain take it with a grain listen
we appreciate you guys coming here
every single thursday 11 a.m eastern
time tell your friends please we need
more vapes
we need more babies we never start this
podcast with anything to talk about we
just sit down and we do
on the on on purpose we go off the cuff
and sometimes i'm like what are we going
to talk about
and i don't think we changed topic and i
looked up and we're at an hour and five
we had a great time and
yeah this is just how it is it's how it
is listen bubs
i mean i love doing this with you where
can people see you outside hey babe uh
savilecanocomedy.com for all dates which
keep getting pushed
because of the pandemic but i'll be
there by a
a i'll be by a theater near you soon
yeah theater yeah
i'm chris d comedy.com stand up date
same thing
some get off the ground some don't it
depends if they push it back at the
pandywandy but i have a podcast
every uh tuesday 11 a.m eastern time
called chrissy chaos so go uh go check
that out my youtube is christy comedy
and just check out taste buds or other
podcasts on the no pressure network it's
a lot of fun
if you like this you'll like that oh
come on
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey